where do things between you and geno
stand today
i don't have any communication with them
and don't don't have any desire it was
god's god's way of saying get out right
now just talking about it
that's not the head space i ever want to
be and ever again you're lighting up you
you have this huge smile on your face
you talk about justin i don't know it's
just different like
you know when you experience true love
for the first time when you know you
know it's just um
mama's home
what are you doing and she's back piling
on more drama
should mama call you and tell you what
she did at the airport just get the
[ __ ] out of your life sniffs me up
mama's selfish ways are tearing us apart
we are so excited about season six of
mama june road to redemption where do
things pick up in the season premiere my
court case was resolved and then
uh juno does and then it goes from there
it just
it talks about a lot of stuff that i
kept behind closed doors which is going
to be very hard because just watching
the first 10 minutes of the first look
um
it kind of like threw me back in that
hit space i was at a year ago which is
it's going to be hard to watch i'm not a
lot of you i'll probably cry i'll
probably
be very quiet because i'm gonna be
watching the show as you're gonna be
watching this show
i have to imagine that there's gonna be
a lot of really challenging moments this
season we've already seen a little you
know preview of those moments in the in
the super trailer there's a lot that
happened behind closed doors that a lot
of people don't know you go back on
whatever you say it's not that easy
mama's bad choices are finally catching
up to her i'm scared i know what gina's
capable of
the end of your relationship with your
ex gino where do things between you and
geno stand today
i don't have any communication with them
and don't don't have any desire
nothing so you you and gino are
absolutely once and for all done for
good been done been done
and how does it feel to have that
chapter of your life in the rear view
mirror
very good very good that is
what i share a lot on the first two
episodes as some stuff i kept behind
closed doors in that
relationship after i think five or six
years together what was it about now
that felt like this is the time for me
to finally close it was god's god's way
of saying get out give him give an open
door because there was many nights of
crying and begging and
seeing god open that door and
it was just that day you know what i'm
saying it gave me the
opportunity to say hey let's get the
hell out of there and that was over a
year ago so i don't look back at that
it's going to be hard to watch the first
couple episodes but i'm happy where i'm
at today i'm very happy in the
relationship i mean i'm happy in the
person i've become happy in my
relationships across the board um
talking about that situation i just it
just puts me in a head space like right
now just talking about it
that's not the head space i ever want to
be in ever again as a result of closing
that chapter of your life has your
relationship with your girls improved
because i know that that was a thing
they were not happy with um yes it has
it has it has um you know because
they've seen everything they've seen you
know uh going through a drug addiction
you know let's go into recovery you know
me getting clean but him falling off the
right it taught me
that
i don't deserve to be there and nobody
deserves to be in that kind of
relationship if you're in a toxic
relationship scream out tell somebody
because i was in that toxic relationship
for more years than i needed to be
more years than i needed to be
100 and i'm so happy to hear that you're
in such a better head space today
of course i i love following a little
glimpses on social media and it sounds
like we're gonna see um your new
relationship with justin mama road to
redemption mama june and her new boy toy
fifty thousand dollars where did she
find these men convicts.com are you in
love yes i've seen them tabloids yes
filming together how much of of justin
are we going to see
um
quite a bit and what has that been like
filming together
um
you know he didn't know who i was to
begin with honestly didn't know and i
mean it was kind of warm because he did
tell them no i don't want to be part of
it i don't want to be i don't want to do
it he had a you know full-time job he
owns businesses he has his own life you
know what i'm saying
so like it has been kind of an
adjustment to him but he's like he got
throwed into it so he's like let's rock
are you telling me after nearly 11 years
in the you know public space justin
didn't know who you were
no
i mean how did you guys meet his
daughter
we met on somebody's tick tock in the
back he was live with somebody and like
if i was sitting right here he was like
behind me like on this side and there
was some other people behind him and
then um i don't know just i just we just
started like chit chatting and
um i started kind of like stalking him
everybody always says he's a clown
chaser i would say from him
okay so it was you who kind of made the
first move yes yes
okay and for anybody who has a negative
opinion or calls him a cop chaser how do
you react to that i'm like no and people
don't realize when me and justin first
met i moved in with him um to his home
we both had our separate homes but you
know i moved in with him and no
definitely not a cloud chaser like he he
does his own stuff
i do my own stuff but we do a lot of
stuff together
what do your girls think of this new
relationship um they like justin they
don't have you know um you know he's
been on vacations with us so it's good
and i know that your your recovery and
your sobriety is is such a
priority in your life right is justin
sober as well i mean how do you guys yes
he's also in recovery he's also in
recovery so how does that work with the
both of you are you uplifting each other
on this journey yes yes yes oh yes so
yes people a lot of people say well two
acts two recovering addicts cannot
who in recovery cannot be together well
that's a lie we're gonna prove that that
little five percent of relationships
don't work we've been through hell and
back uh we've known each other for a
year most relationships don't go through
the obstacles that we have had to go
through the last year
um and they don't even go through it in
their lifetime of their relationship so
i think honestly that's made us stronger
i mean knowing the journey that you were
on in your past romantic relationship
and now seeing
you're you're lighting up you you have
this smile on your face you talk about
justin what's the big difference in this
relationship that you work
so many so many things um
one like
he is helping put the pieces back with
me because i told him i'm broken like
i'm not you know there's still like
things that like they can like trigger
me so then he
tries to like help with that if that
makes sense but he is like
the most loving the most
i don't know it's just different like
you know when you experience true love
for the first time and he is seven years
seven years and 11 months younger than
me and when you experience that for the
first time guys
it you know when you know you know it's
it's kind of a crazy you know he's my
fifth serious relationship and
it's just um
there's rumors that you're engaged mama
june what do you say to that well look
baby i've had this ring on my hand
for nine years um i have been you know
i'm saying so
there is no different room because he
was like oh you know look case is my
favorite jewelry store
and who knows what the future holds
honestly
um so we're gonna see
[Music]
you